[inaudible] trans part of this all fit
in because I remember years ago when
people would say, when I, when everyone
started saying the LGBT community,
I remember thinking,
I have no more insight
into the t part of this,
then a straight CIS gendered heterosexual
male. Would, you know what I mean?
I just,
I don't,
I maybe I have somehow slightly a
little more inherent empathy by being an
outsider at some level,
but I don't have any more knowledge of it.
And now it seems like the Trans issue
has almost superseded all of the other
issues at least in the last
year. I mean everywhere. Yeah.
Everywhere you go there's, you know, every
time I opened the Twitter search bar,
it's another trans story or someone's
being fired for this joke or that or the
other.
What do you think happened there that
catapulted this so quickly and what are
the issues around it that were kind of
afraid to talk about right now? Yeah,
it's a really complicated fraught topic.
I think trying to get you, I think like
the legitimate issue about trans is
there are people who are trans or field
trans and they want their rights respected
and that's totally legitimate and
good for them.
And raising awareness about that is fine.
There's a much larger group of people
who I think are using trans issues as a
kind of wedge to destroy,
uh,
the gender binary or to kind of muddy
the waters or basically as a weapon to
beat up evolutionary psychology
or evolutionary biology
to say there's no such
thing as sex.
Really.
There's no such thing as biological
sex or sex is totally dissociated from
gender,
etc. When someone says that,
and the next time someone
says that on Twitter,
what's the answer that the
person watching this should give?
That maybe Twitter is not
the best one for it? I mean,
male and female or evolved strategies
that exist because over thousands of
generations they were like the
paths to successful reproduction.
Um,
if you're not clearly male and functioning
as a male or you're not clearly
female and functioning as a female,
you're your genetic dead end.
So selection hammers
against any ambiguity there.
So it's not surprising that the vast
majority of humans alive today clearly
identify as one sex or the other.
Um,
that doesn't mean everyone should,
it doesn't have any kind of
moral implications about that.
But just descriptively it means there is
a gender binary and it evolved for good
reasons.
And everyone who teaches biology hopefully
knows this and it shouldn't be that
controversial right now.
If we want to like genetically engineer
people and use and whatever to destroy
the gender binary for the
22nd and 23rd centuries,
we can do that. We could
talk about that. Um,
I don't have any particular
attachment to the kind of male,
female dichotomy ethically.
Um,
but I think descriptively it's really
important to kind of accept it and to go,
if it's here,
it's valuable to understand
and we shouldn't necessarily
try to pretend it out
of existence,
um,
or pretend that we're doing it in
the name of Trans Rights, right?
You can have trans rights without
saying there's no such thing as sex.
So this gets to the heart of what I
think is really happening in this country
right now,
which is everything has become politicized
to the point that the experts in the
field seem afraid to talk
to you right now are,
are taking a risk by talking
about these issues. Yeah.
Are you seeing this across the board?
Are you seeing this amongst colleagues
if fear to talk about these things? Yeah,
absolutely.
Now the vast majority of people like at
my university don't really touch upon
anything that's particularly politicized,
right?
They're just teaching civil
engineering or law or um,
immunology or whatever.
And most of that isn't
really politicized yet,
however yet is the key word
that. Right, right. Okay.
I mean you get a little bit bit about
what's the gender representation in
certain fields, but in my
department, in psychology,
you do get almost everything
having a kind of political edge.
And I have colleagues who are
frightened to teach certain classes.
Like I teach psychology of
human sexuality and I'm,
I'm pretty upfront outspoken about
what I cover and what my view is,
but a lot of my colleagues will not touch
it with a barge pole because there's
so much risk that students will just get
upset about one little thing you say.
Yeah. And complained to a dean and
then you'll get called into the office.
And, um, so what would
be that type of thing,
but beyond what you just said about the,
and the evidence of,
of gender differences,
what,
what are the other types of things
that just talking about are scaring the
academics?
It's very awkward to talk about sex
differences in any mental traits or
motivations or preferences. It's hard
to talk about sexual coercion, rape,
pate, rape, harassment, stall gang,
etc. That was being incredibly
difficult one at college. Yeah. Yeah.
Um, it's hard to talk about,
um, aggression in general,
either between individuals or between
groups and how that relates to sexuality.
Like why hunter gatherer tribes go to war,
right?
It's not typically about land or food,
it's about women.
And that doesn't fit the kind of
Marxist picture of prehistoric warfare.
Right.
And then if you talk about stuff like,
um, pregnancy, childcare, parenting,
are you being,
you know,
overly pro natalist and sort of family
values for talking about that stuff?
Is that alienating to certain students
who might be homosexual or infertile or,
or adopted kids or whatever?
Um,
but you see,
it's so interesting because I obviously
hear these types of stories from
academics all the time,
not only in here but,
but online and people email me all the
time and it's like, God, we've failed.
I mean, the university really
had failed at that point.
Like if you're afraid to talk about child
rearing because that might upset a gay
person. Yeah. Jesus. I mean,
what's left at that point?
It's so frustrating and it means
I feel bad for the students.
But I also feel bad for the parents
who are often footing the tuition bill
because the parents have faith that if I
send my kid to a state university and I
paid tens of thousands and tuition
and they take a course on topic x,
like human sexuality,
that they're going to get professors who
are willing to profess to say what they
really think and often
and not getting that.
So there's a kind of bait and switch
where universities are pretending to be
these bastions of free speech
and inquiry and, and honesty.
And in fact,
um,
everyone's kind of running scared and
these kids are not getting our best
insights. They're paying the money,
but we're not delivering the service.
How much of an infection, not just
in the classroom, do you see this as,
but I think,
correct me if I'm wrong,
I think you've written around 110
published papers. Is that right?
Did I get the exact number right? Is it a
hundred more or less? More, more or less?
You lose count anything at some point.
I'm sure you're well aware
of the Peter you led hoax,
that it's not just what's happening in
the classroom that's causing the chaos,
but it actually may be what's happening
before that related to all of these
papers that at certain
disciplines basically have,
I don't think I'm all the rest of waiting.
They almost have no standards. Yeah.
At this point that that has got to be
just incredibly frustrating for someone
that actually has published some things
legitimately. It's kind of frustrating,
but I can see you don't get frustrated
easily. But I'm like, it doesn't matter
bug me as much as maybe it
bugged some other people.
Partly because I spent a
lot of my undergraduate, um,
years taking courses on critical
theory and I read a lot of dairy,
dawn Foucault and,
and all those French dudes.
And one reason I loved those courses is
it was so easy to get an a by writing a
kind of bullshit paper using the right
terms and ma using sufficiently obscure
syntax. Right. That, so
I know that game. God,
that's real. Very well. It's
really real and it's great fun.
I understand the appeal of that stuff.
It's just,
I can't imagine spending my adult
life doing nothing about that.
And that's what's happening
in a lot of the humanities.
So it like if,
if those folks want to
do that and get paid,
typically not a very good
salary to do that. I don't,
it doesn't really viscerally offends me.
The only dangerous when is when they
turn into activists and they give people
like me grief based on not
understanding what I do.
Well, I would imagine a lot of
bitches then leaks into your classroom
and then, and all bets
are off. It's weird.
It doesn't actually leak in. Like
when I teach human sexuality, right.
The kids have a sort of vague,
um,
political correctness that
they've absorbed mostly in
k through 12 public school,
I think.
But if you actually ask them,
have you had any courses
on gender feminism? No.
Have you heard of any of these leading
figures from critical theory or history
of feminism or even history of gay rights?
I know nothing about.
So it's not like they've
been indoctrinated,
at least not in big state schools,
but they've kind of soaked up
some stuff from high school.
I think that influences how
they interpret everything.
So as two guys
wearing, might I say very nice
shirts right now is shiny,
terrible shirt and a shiny blue shirt.
Let's talk about evolutionary aesthetics.
Toll people don't talk about aesthetics.
Yeah that much.
But you think that sort of the things
we're looking at in the west or maybe not
as exciting as they should be and
that there's a problem there, is that
fair to say?
Yeah,
I've been really into art for a long
time and I think art and beauty are
important,
um,
particularly to places
people live and work.
And I think as humans we kind of
deserve the best from artists,
interior designers, stylists, whatever,
architects that make our
lives as pleasant as possible.
And I think basically
ever since about 1910,
art in architecture has failed and has
not done a very good job of delivering
visual environments that are actually
humane and appealing and enjoyable and
that kind of promote
mental and physical health.
What happened around
19 modernism, man, um,
if you look at the way
domestic architecture worked
up until about that period,
it was all sort of human scale
and arts and crafts and um,
there are places you'd want to live where
you didn't have to be educated into a
particular elite notion of what a house
should be in order to appreciate it.
Right? And then you get the bow
house, international modernism,
white structures, crisp hard lines, um,
bad acoustics.
And suddenly that becomes
the fashion right?
And that becomes what people think
or is the future and nobody likes it,
but it's kind of imposed
top down by the elite.
You must live like this,
like it or not.
Is that top down from the elite or is
that just that often those things are just
easier to build probably and cheaper to
build or maybe that's the same. Actually
the irony is like you
could have taken cheap,
easy to build reinforced concrete
structures and built a lot of all,
some cheap houses that were okay or
you could do the traditional route,
but instead of what you get is every
house must be distinct and must have its
own shape and there can't be any,
um,
standardization.
So the houses end up being expensive and
experimental and hard to maintain and
they leak and everyone's miserable.
Um,
so they're not really serving the needs
of the, the people at large. They're just
great for architect egos.
Yeah.
It's interesting because I just spent a
couple of months bouncing through a lot
of different countries in Europe and
especially on most of these countries
because the history goes back so far.
You seem incredible architecture.
You see eating,
you know,
I'd see chairs that were 150 years old
and like the woodwork that would go into
it in the craftsmen shit.
And it was like,
I don't think we could do this
today or if we could do it today,
this would've caught,
this chair would be in our dollars.
It would be like a 6,000, $500
chair, where back then, you know,
this is what a guy did.
It took them a couple of days and he could
sell it and earn a wage and it's like
we've just, the economics of
everything had gotten out of whack.
Yeah.
And like nice table here.
Um, this slash probably slide it on
the table right when you walked in.
So I know you mean it.
Yeah. Um, I've made a few pieces
of furniture in my day and that's,
that's pretty cool. But yeah, it
was a visual art in particular. Um,
the economics mean like abstract painting
just is so much faster to do than
representational painting,
right.
If you're a young aspiring artist and
you want a career and you want to give
your gallery a certain flow
of work that they can sell,
it's a lot harder to do that.
If you're doing representational
paintings that take a hundred,
300 hours than an abstract
work that takes a 10th of that.
So the economic pressures are
also in that direction. Yeah.
Um, but people have, um,
kind of voted with their feet and like
they don't like elite abstract art.
They don't like conceptual art. Um, it's,
I like the word the right word.
They or are, they just don't,
they just don't know where
it's conditioning or it's
that we all like to like
what everybody else likes
sort of thing.
I think everybody knows that that
kind of supposed to enjoy going to,
like while we're visiting the city,
we should go to the contemporary art
museum and they get there and there's a
bunch of terrible video art and there's
a bunch of very puzzling conceptual art.
And they read the little descriptions
on the walls and they go,
it just makes no sense cause it's
written by an art curator for other art
curators. And it's all completely
alienating. And that's,
that's sad because it means they're being
told this is the highest expression of
your culture,
but it's completely inaccessible to you.
So what,
uh,
what do you look at that gives you some
excitement or can still sort of renew
your spirit, let's say? Well, there
is a movement of kind of neo
traditionalism and, and art where there's,
there's certain places like New York
Academy of Arts that are actually teaching
students how to draw and
paint and sculpt and,
and do the sort of traditional,
um,
skills that people associate with art.
Um,
it's just a little hard
to get a foothold in the,
like the New York or London gallery
system if that's the kind of work that you
do.
Um,
but my hope is that like
the bay area billionaires,
we'll start collecting that stuff. Um,
I think the Chinese aren't market is,
has got a real thirst for
good representational art
and I think that's going to
start to dominate the
art world pretty soon.
So what's the evolutionary
need for good art? I mean,
what's the psychological, I
mean, I know you're, you're okay.
There's an expression of something
that can't quite be said,
but what's like the
driving force behind that?
So yeah, on the one hand there's, why do
we bother to make art? On the other hand,
why,
why do we like certain kinds of art?
And there's been a lot more research
on why did we like certain kinds of
patterns and colors and forms
and compensations and whatever.
But there's no sort of unified theory of,
of aesthetics.
In fact,
I would say there's more
good stuff published on that
topic between about 1817,
1920 than since.
Cause that's when people were
sort of there inspired by Darwin.
Evolutionary aesthetics was a field.
There were dozens of books published on
it and then modernism came and everyone
forgot all of that.
How could this be connected to the
earlier topic, which is sexuality.
So for example,
my gay male friends generally speaking,
have a much better eye for art
or for style or for fashion.
Yeah. You know, you could get away
in that crew. You know what I mean?
Like you've got a nice blanket on,
you got an make shirt like that.
You know what I mean? Like, I mean that
is a compliment. Like where Jay, again,
just broadly speaking,
it's like my straight guy friends,
all kinds of wear big shirts and they
don't know exactly how to do their hair
and their,
you know,
so there's some connection between
sexuality and artistic vision.
I think that's absolutely true.
And it's not what you would predict from
first principles. It's really weird.
If you look around at other species,
the males are typically
much more ornamental than
the females. They have the,
the amazing plumage and
they do the incredible songs
and dances and the females
are usually kind of drab and,
and not that aesthetic.
The power birds that make these
incredible kind of installation works.
That's all the males. Then you get
to humans or at least American males,
American straight nails.
And it's like,
can't you even find clothes that fit?
We'd like colors.
That is the big shift work.
And like what is up with your house?
You know?
And when I did the,
you're in Peter's until 2 million copies
to tell people to clean their room.
Yeah.
So I have no idea why gay men have
better taste than straight men.
I think that's a fascinating,
there's some,
there has to be some
something going on there. Um,
but I think men can level up obviously
cause like British and European men
aren't as hopeless.
If you grow up a young man in Italy,
you kind of absorb some ideas about
style and even the British um,
kind of aristocrats landed,
gentry class have a certain look that
it's a bit traditionalist but at least
there's taste.
I don't know if he's
going to quite make sense,
but where we almost getting there say
10 years ago with the rise of the metro
sexual.
Yeah man,
it's sort of crashed because I guess
maybe it relates back to what you said at
the beginning about where
we are more puritan.
So where there was this idea there
was this like mocking of them like Ah,
they're just gay but don't want to
admit it. Or something like that.
And that whole thing seem to crash.
Like there was this little brief window
where straight guys were like dressing
better had cooler haircuts or something,
something there.
Well, even five years ago when I lived
in New York for a little bit and uh,
hung out, hung out a lot in
Brooklyn, there was sort of,
that was peak hipster in
Brooklyn and the guys there,
the straight guys put a lot of effort
into grooming and haircuts and authentic
style and this or that is in fashion.
And I thought this is really cool.
This is like a Europeanization
of male taste and culture,
but it was also very masculine.
It wasn't sort of like late seventies
disco culture or early nineties rave
culture or,
or burning man culture.
You sort of more old school
masculinity school. Yeah.
Like I want to go to a proper barber
and get proper haircut and like it's all
flannel and boots and whatever
and I love that stuff. Um,
but I think it kind of had its moment
and evaporated on it.
They just priced themselves
out of the market and Brooke,
right? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Or they just got all too busy on Twitter.
Well that it always comes back to that.
Let's talk a little bit about mate
selection. Regardless of your sexuality,
there seems to be this new thing right
now where if you're not open to dating,
absolutely anyone under any circumstances,
no matter how they look or how they
take care of themselves or whether they
brush their teeth or whether they have a
penis or a vagina or any combination of
anything that if you are
just open to anything,
there is a a pretty loud and growing
boys out there that is trying to frame
everyone as a,
as a pig,
which is the reverse of what choosing
a mate really has been about.
It's insane. I mean, for 500
I got you. I got emotional.
There were
500 million years,
right?
Our vertebrate ancestors
have been choosing the mates
selectively because that
is the highest stakes decision
any organism makes as who
do I recombine my jeans
with?
Right?
And so all the way through the coordinates
and the vertebrates in the mammals
and the primates,
you get,
particularly females being choosy
about, you know, who they breed with,
who sires their kids,
but then as fit as humans start doing
pair bonds million 2 million years ago and
the males start investing
more in offspring,
start forming longer term relationships,
then we also have incentives to
be choosy about our female mates.
And so this is the one domain where if
you have even a shred of libertarian in
you or you respect freedom
of association at all,
or you think it's okay to care who you
spend your life with and like what kind
of children you,
you create,
then mate choice should be
it kind of domain of freedom,
right? Like this is a good place to be
prejudice, so to speak, right? Yeah.
Like you should add some,
uh,
it should just be discriminating,
have judgment on taste and you can
always be open to the idea that maybe the
current set of criteria that I have maybe
could be nudged or improved or tweaked
or maybe I'm subject to
certain stereotypes and
maybe I could overcome those.
True,
of course people tend to get better at
may choice in their thirties and in their
teens.
But for someone to start
lecturing you politically,
like you shouldn't be attracted to women.
You should be attracted to anybody or any,
any kind of being or in any
species and the age like,
no,
let please let me be attracted to,
I'm attracted to because
that should be like the,
the pinnacle of human freedom. Yeah. If,
if you don't believe in
freedom anywhere else,
you should believe in mate choice freedom.
It should be a fundamental
human right I think.
And where you get horrible
to tal in societies,
really infringing on mate choice freedom.
Like you're not allowed to
marry that person or you know,
you have to do an arranged
marriage to that person.
We kind of recoil at that and go,
that's horrible.
And yet in America we have busy bodies,
virtue signalers um,
telling us your may choice
criteria are too narrow.
So where
do gay people fit in all of this then
out of biological or an evolutionary
perspective, you've brought up the
point of passing on genes, man,
gay couples or gay people, whether
you're a couple or not. Don't do that.
At least biologically speaking.
Yup.
Um,
so what,
what do you make of that condition?
Is that even the right word?
And I'm going to get,
I'm going to get us both in trouble.
Probably just for me asking the question.
Let's call it a trait trait traits.
Pretty neutral. Okay. Alright. Trey,
it's pretty neutral.
Well,
here's the fascinating
thing about homosexuality is
people have been developing
or trying to develop series
of male homosexuality and
it's kind of evolutionary
origins and functions for 30,
40 years and there is no
good theory of it yet.
It's a complete mystery.
I've never seen any compelling
explanation of male homosexuality.
So, so what would be a compelling
compelling argument would be,
okay.
There's costs of being like exclusively
attracted to your own sex and therefore
not typically having as many kids,
but there's some countervailing
benefits of some sort,
maybe benefits to your extended family
or benefits to your group or something
else. But nobody can make
the math work enough to,
to kind of explain that. Um,
female bisexuality is much easier,
right?
You can go,
well as long as a woman is sometimes
attracted to men enough to have kids,
then also being attracted to women might
be no cost at all or it might even be a
benefit in terms of social networking,
making friends sex as a great
way to make friends. Um,
if a lot more males were bisexual,
that would be equally easy to explain.
Um,
it's exclusive homosexuality,
that's very hard to explain.
It certainly exists that exists at a,
you know,
a percentage that's much,
much higher than you can explain is just,
well, it's just mutations where it's
just maladaptive. That won't work.
So this is where I'll be Kinda
epistemically humble and say,
man, I have no idea. It's an,
it's a fascinating problem.
Maybe somebody will
crack it within 10 or 20.
Right.
It's interesting because if you were
coming at it from another perspective,
like a religious perspective,
let's say you would find that to be
a moral quandary that then you could
extrapolate that all sorts of
different judgements on, yeah.
But I can see the way you answered
it, it's like just is a thing. Yeah.
Maybe we'll get more data on it,
but it is,
but what do you make of the fact that
there are seemingly many more bisexual
women where,
I don't know any gay couple that wanted
the guys sneaking out at night to bang a
woman.
Never heard of that.
But you have heard of
obviously straightened couples
where the guy is, you know,
on the DL or whatever.
Yeah.
Well my girlfriend Diana Fleishman has
a whole theory of female bisexuality.
That's, that's to do with the
social networking benefits. Um,
but then the question is, yeah, why
don't the men do that too? Cause like,
okay,
if, if you're a guy and you
kind of swing both ways,
then like doing gay sex can be a
great way to make male friends also.
And it's,
well now I know we have our,
uh, our promo for the show.
And so in a way the quandary isn't
why do any male homosexual is exist.
The quandary is why aren't all
males and females bisexual?
And do you think some of that years from
now we might look back and go, Whoa,
that's just societal pressure.
It might be.
I think certainly there's a huge amount
of stigma against male bisexuals from
both sexes, but especially women. Um,
female bisexuality used to be stigmatized
maybe 30 years ago and not so much
anymore. Yeah. So it could change.
What are some of the
other topics that are,
that are really on your mind these days?
Let's hit up effective altruism.
Yeah, let's talk about that.
Um,
I don't know if you've had many guests
on talking about effective altruism,
but it's not a tight,
actually,
it's sort of my hot topic
of the last few years.
So it's a social movement
on moral movement.
It's some of the smartest
young people I've ever met.
And their basic goal in
life is do the most good.
They can based on reason and evidence
rather than sentimentality and virtue
signaling.
I've done a little bit of this sort of
in an ancillary way with some of the
libertarians that, yeah, yeah. Yeah.
And so the kind of major domains they
tend to focus on are things like how do we
get charities to be more effective at
reducing global poverty or promoting
global public health?
How do we overcome factory farming and
be nice to animals and promote animal
welfare?
And so a lot of the effect of altruists
are Vegan for ethical reasons.
And then a lot of them are focused
on just survival of the species.
How do we reduce existential risks to
humanity like nuclear war bioweapons,
um,
and artificial intelligence risks.
So maybe the most distinctive thing
they have is this kind of ultra longterm
perspective that's like,
we are just these transient little beings.
The thing that really matters
is what is humanity turn into?
How long do we last?
Do we colonize the universe or do we fail?
And folks who think most seriously about
that think it's actually that lasting,
minimizing existential risk that is
absolutely crucial and everything else is
just kind of fluff and bullshit
like the transhumanist who would sort
of fit within them. Is there a risk?
So I love this stuff
because I'm a Scifi guy.
Everything I mentioned
Philip k Dick before,
I mean every one of his stories or books
or about the inevitability of all of
these things.
Is there a risk though?
I'm always looking at what's beyond the
horizon instead of going on right now.
I don't really think there's a risk
unless like the vast majority of humans
became effective altruists there's already
so many people who are obsessed with
um,
you know,
diversity and equity and inclusion and
economic growth and all the ordinary
problems that politicians talk about
that that's covered this already.
A lot of smart people working on that.
The big neglected topics tend to be the
kind of science fictiony topics where
you need a sort of cadre of genius as BS,
right. To work on it when nobody
else is taking it seriously.
Yeah.
Well speaking of they ask me is that,
that's an interesting whatever we
wanted to get into it. That's a little,
a little controversial as well.
Um,
what is that all about?
That so many of the creators now or the
people that are coming out of the tech
world,
even though you can obviously make plenty
of arguments at the tech world is now
in his of implosion and
certainly not the creative
place it was say 10 years ago,
but that's so much creativity came out
of a world that had so many people that
were seemingly uncreated.
[inaudible]
I think it's fascinating.
Um,
I sort of identify as moderately Osby
myself kind of high functioning asbergers
and I've written some stuff about how um,
neurodiversity issues like being asked
to kind of rub up against free speech
issues cause like can you explain
that over people who are asked,
we don't always do a good
job of understanding the
beliefs and desires of other
people and particularly what
they might find offensive, right?
So they might just say something
so they might just say shit.
And then these really surprised
that it was distressing to someone.
And so if you have a model of speech
that says you must never cause a fence,
that assumes you can anticipate
what will cause a fence,
and a lot of people can't anticipate
that because their brains don't work that
way.
So you either need to say, okay, as bs,
you can never say anything
or cut them some slack and say,
we understand you'll offend
people once in awhile,
but that's okay because that's
just, that's part of your deal, man.
I've never thought about this,
but does this somehow explain
what's going on in Silicon Valley?
Right now you have a bunch of people
who are somewhat socially awkward,
let's say,
created incredible technology
that allowed us to all connect,
but then when voices that are exposed,
I suppose that's a horrible way of
framing it within voices that are a little
out there or a little contrary or whatever
that might include us actually get
out there.
The only way they can deal with it is
to shut that voice off or something like
that.
Like,
which is why we're seeing
so much d platforming and
silencing and they're right.
They have to be overly systematizing about
it, that they have to be like, oh man,
I can't,
I can't navigate these gray areas if
I'm running a social media platform or
Patrion or whatever.
Right?
So I'm gonna just have a hard and
fast rule that says if I get enough
complaints,
I d platform that person or um,
okay.
I don't know the difference between porn
and erotica and just slightly sexy art.
So I'm going to say no
nipples or whatever.
That's a kind of asked be
response to getting blow back
from people were like, you don't really
know why they're upset. So in a weird way,
if you have a bunch of the creators of
Silicon Valley then are coming from that
world and then you suddenly bring in a
bunch of executives that come from the
social justice world that really shows
like a, uh, that's a match made in hell.
Right? It's just matter.
Anti matter. Yeah. It's, um,
it's terrible.
And
what I hoped would happen is that maybe
five or 10 years ago it seemed like,
Whoa,
like tech is dominating culture generally,
and tech is dominated by ASP ease.
So hopefully ask me values of being kind
of tolerant and eccentric and nerdy and
like getting weird little enthusiasms
that that would kind of trickle down and
create a more tolerant culture.
Is that what you would have predicted,
say 10 years ago? Yeah, really.
And instead you have the opposite.
You have the social justice activists
taking over and basically saying
all of that quirky freedoms that you,
you asked the people value,
we're going to legislate that away.
You can't have that.
Um, and it's, it's tragic.
I hope the pendulum swing swings back,
but um,
as long as the leaders of the social media
platforms don't have the guts to say,
look, this is our people. Um,
outspoken,
eccentric,
slightly socially oblivious
people and that's okay.
And the rest of you just have to
kind of suck it up and deal with it.
That's what they should be doing.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
I met the point with all of this and
you know how friends from Youtube and
Twitter and patriotic and the whole thing,
I'm really at the point of this where I
actually believe that that solution is
gone. I don't think it can come from the
top anymore. I really don't believe that.
I think that thing has become so corroded
that I would say the only way it can
come is now from the bottom and then the
people will basically rise up against
these things and I know that it's sort
of pie in the sky because what does that
even mean? Do we all sign off on the
same day? Do we all bet? You know,
whatever that means.
But I almost see that as the only
way to do this because they've had,
we've done everything else or,
or the governmental get involved in.
That certainly rings all the bells that
I'm not happy with on my libertarian
side.
Yeah. I, I think at least
in terms of universities,
the only solution to,
to some of the university problems is the
government actually saying at least to
the public universities that are in
principle bound by the constitution.
You guys have to obey the first
amendment or you lose federal funding.
I think that's the only leverage.
Yeah.
And I was really kind of hoping that
POTUS would do that at some point in the
last year or two and pretty
disappointed that he hasn't,
well, in a weird way he almost benefits
the more that they go against it. Right.
Because that feeds his base of yeah.
Aggrieved and politically correct. Yeah.
You know that they see political
correctness running amok. Yeah.
Something like that. Um, all right.
Before we finish up gimme gimme one thing
where at the beginning of 2019 right
now, give me one thing that we should
be sort of thinking about that we're not
thinking about now.
I love the thought experiment of like,
once Elon Musk succeeds and
we start colonizing Mars,
what,
what are the relationships and social
structures in the Mars colonies going to
look like?
I'm fascinated by this,
this issue like barred the
colonies going to be like
communist utopia is are they
going to be libertarian, um,
aspirational states?
Are they,
is everyone going to do
monogamous lifelong marriage?
Is it going to be crazy polyamorous,
kinky stuff?
I think it's great to think about
this stuff before we attempt it.
And I think Mars is going to
be this amazing experiment,
or like this colony gets formed based on
these social and sexual assumptions and
this one gets formed and this
one fails catastrophic Lee or,
or it's like,
it doesn't work well then often it's just
borrows the organization of this other
place.
So I think it'll be this incredible kind
of behavioral science laboratory and I
can't
where I say that's not too far from the
way the America we set up. Right, exactly.
To be those places of experiment.
Yeah. Um, it's, yeah,
it's the way the east coast was 200
and 250 years ago and I think, um,
the difference now is the colonies will
be able to communicate with each other
and with us and be able to measure
a bunch of outcomes and deliberately
experiment.
And I think we need to kind of get out
ahead of that and start like rereading
all of our classic science fiction and
figuring out how is this going to apply
for reals now,
now that we
do it. Yeah. Which is still related
to why you think art is important?
Because fiction's just as important.
I mean,
you realize it all lands that
eventually they figure it out.
They have their tea party and
then we blow them up like, yeah,
but they do beautiful art nouveau
like domes in the meanwhile.
Yeah. Jeffrey, I'm so glad we finally
did this and listen to it again for sure.
And if you want to see a
good combination of bright,
smart thought and snark on Twitter,
follow Jeffrey at primal Polly
[inaudible].